(funky music)
- I think the only real
way to push a eco-conscious
agenda is to just make the
things that are eco-conscious
a little more sexy.
Ready Freddie?
(grinder whirring)
My name is Josh Hadar,
I'm a metal sculptor.
My artistic platform is
sculptures, bikes, that all
have the same theme of
eco-consciousness and sustainability.
Aahh!
Whoo, solar energy.
There are lots of
electric bikes out there,
but, you know, I don't think you're
going to get a whole lot of
interest without that bike
being a real head-turner.
(welder snapping)
I learned how to weld at
the university of YouTube.
(laughing)
I didn't really have
anything in mind to build
when I started to weld.
I just loved the process.
(welding buzzing)
This bike not only runs on solar energy,
but it was completely
created by solar energy.
The same system that I use
to power the batteries,
I use to power all my
hand tools, and basically,
all of these are made
strictly by hand tools.
And then, basically, once you buy it,
there's virtually no costs.
You know, you don't have to
gas it up, you don't whatever,
solar, it's from the
sky, it's from the sun.
Once I had my kids, my
priorities really changed
and that was just, you know, bI
want a cleaner planet.